actress Diane Carroll is being
remembered for her versatile work on
Broadway television and as a singer she
died Friday after a long battle with
breast cancer she was 84 cherrylle
garnered critical acclaim for her
pioneering work on television Diahann
Carroll changed the course of television
history in 1968 she became the first
african-american woman to star as
someone other than a domestic worker in
the groundbreaking sitcom Julia a role
for which she won a Golden Globe I'm
colleague what color I am I'm a negro
you always been a Negro you just trying
to be fashionable Carol was a native New
Yorker verse made it big on Broadway
breaking barriers on stage is the first
black woman to win a Tony Award for Best
Leading Actress in a Musical for her
role in no-strings
execute she would go on to make it on
the big screen the 1974 film Claudine
provided her largest movie roles she
played a hard-working single mom of six
who falls in love with a garbage man
played by James Earl Jones
in the 1980s Carol joined the
long-running primetime soap opera
dynasty
Dominique Deborah I intend to have a
memorable stay she followed that with a
number of guest roles in TV series
including a different world for which
she received an Emmy nomination
Carol spoke proudly about her
decades-long career I'm happy
deliriously so about having had this
career and for so many african-american
women I would I would just say all women
she was such a proud woman
and seeing her on dynasty Woolf which
was already my favorite show that's what
I was gonna say for me to see her I
didn't know the background until I
watched her on dynasty and my mom said
you need to look back and see these
others she's so stunning it's done
elegant oh I thought she did a great job
thank you saw her as a role model
Dominic Deveraux the dynasty that's a
whole other story